hello everyone I'm very happy to be back
at Pi data Global for another year
running uh this year talking on data
science project patterns that work
so what is uh the point of today's talk
so here I'm going to present some
patterns for Success so this talk is
aimed at teams who have trouble
delivering valuable results so I work
with a lot of different teams if you're
a high performance team and you often
ship high value results internally then
you'll get some tips from this talk but
really this uh this talk is aimed at
teams that are having trouble repeatedly
and reliably shipping valuable end
results I'm going to show some common
situations that make failures more
likely
and then I'll develop some success
patterns which hopefully will give you a
terminology that you can use to discuss
in your teams with your internal clients
to make success more likely
um using these ideas I've been I've been
using these ideas for years here I'm
trying to encode them as patterns for
the first time and I've made a lot of
money for a bunch of clients as I've
been in the industry for over 20 years
so I'm pretty uh pretty happy to be
sharing it I think they're right but I'd
like your feedback so feedback in
Discord would be amazing uh please take
these uh pattern ideas back to your team
and discuss them and see which of them
you can adapt for internal usage so what
is this pattern that I'm talking about
you may be aware of software design
patterns things like the visitor pattern
and the Singleton of the factory the
idea of design patterns goes further
back to the design of architecture and
physical places and Gardens and all
sorts before the software world and the
the gang of four design patterns book
the notion is to develop some kind of
pattern that identifies a common
situation which will give you uh
guidance towards an answer that will
lead you to success where you could
repeat that that pattern and that route
to success a million different ways and
still get to the kind of end results
that you're after uh so I'm trying to
encourage some of these lessons as these
patterns and there's a notion of
anti-patent as well so commonly used
processes that feel like a good idea at
the time and they're super common I see
them all the time in my Consulting but
they lead to a substandard result things
go wrong if you follow the anti pattern
so I'll highlight those as well during
this talk
so who am I I'm an interim Chief data
scientist I go and work with teams where
they're lacking a senior and then I help
her bring some senior experience to the
team I've been in the domain for over 20
years I used to write a lot of
intellectual property and then I started
doing training and doing intellectual
property development and then
increasingly I've moved to strategy so
helping teams and data science leaders
and ctOS and CEOs develop the right kind
of strategy and ecosystem in a company
that lets the data scientists do
valuable work rather than giving them
silly projects that don't work
so here I'm sharing from one of my
courses my successful data science
projects course I've got a bunch of
ideas from there that I'm sharing for
you today I talk about this on my
newsletter that's called not a number
dot email play on floating Point number
errors so not a number it has a whole
bunch of uh archives just got a website
the archives are available free and I
talk about these kind of topics there
and I talk about high performance python
which is the books that I co-wrote with
Misha gorillik and I share high
performance ideas because I'm all about
developing our ideas quickly as well so
that we can ship value quickly into our
internal users and I'm one of the
co-founders of Pi data London with our
11 000 members over eight years of
growth in our volunteer run group I'm
super proud of what we have here in
London with our PI data environment
so let's start at the beginning which
project should we choose
now in a young data science team or a
data science Team without strong
leadership often we've got a plus a wide
variety of possible projects in front of
us and so uh then what do we do what do
we choose uh which ones are most
exciting which ones are most likely to
generate change uh inside our
organization and what are the pitfalls
and it's really hard to see that
particularly when you're a junior team
you don't have political control you
don't have good political cover in the
organization you're a young team and
you're asked to do magic because the
whole world knows data science is all
about magic to turn data into some kind
of value and so we don't have all of the
normal support that we'd like to have so
we're looking for a high chance of
positive results and we're exception
that there's High uncertainty in our
environment but we don't know what we
should be doing and a common mistake
here is selling a big outcome but
ignoring all of the risks and then
hoping for the best and I've been told
repeatedly in various engagements Ian
you're worrying too much stop stressing
about all of that we'll get to that
later on it's not really going to be a
problem you're just worrying too much at
the beginning just keep typing and
learned that's a really really bad idea
we shouldn't just keep typing we should
ask lots of interesting questions and
I'll give you an example of a negative
story that got turned around this is
walking from the box to the database one
of my insurance client stories I was
asked to work on a novel a novel pricing
algorithm to outperform the actuaries in
a young data science team out on the
procedures in this team and we weren't
allowed to talk to the actuaries or it
would be a bad sign when you can't
collaborate with the people who know the
most in an organization and we were told
look we've already sold the success of
this project you're delivering three
million in value in in six months time
uh just go and make it work I said well
great have we have we looked at the data
if we checked that the client needs this
how are we going to integrate it oh no
we'll just get to those bits later just
go and ship that value and I kept on
getting the data kept on meeting
different people kept saying hey the
data that I'm being given seems to be
partial I've got a bit over here and a
bit over here but the jigsaw pieces
aren't coming together there's no
coherent View and I seem to be missing a
whole pile of columns and necessary
information and in the end one of my
colleagues are looking and why won't you
go with one of the underwriters go to
the office there so go to the box go to
the uh the Lloyd of London building and
sit there and watch them interacting
with clients see them writing things
down and typing on their keyboards as
they put insurance quotes together and
then walk the data back that's a
brilliant idea I'm going to walk the
whole process so I sat with my colleague
or I watched him ask questions I asked
him questions I went back to the office
I asked them questions I saw them do
this and this and this and they've got
these interesting bits of data but I
don't see that in the database where is
it then I discovered oh some of that's
on the Excel machine over there and some
of that's on Excel over there and some
of that's on the the printed documents
that get scanned in but never typed into
a database some of that's in last year's
database some of it's in the database
that will be coming next year and I
realized actually that data organization
was incoherent it was all there nothing
was lost it was all legal and correct
and priced appropriately but there was
no data for a data scientist to work off
so I abandoned that project gathered a
small group of people we came up with a
change strategy so the organization
could develop a coherent data strategy
so that a data scientist in the future
could developed the kind of algorithms
now it wasn't the answer that was this
one and it wasn't the project that I
wanted to do but it was the project that
the business needed such that it could
ship value at some point in the future
asking these questions is incredibly
important
so let's start with our first pattern a
pattern that I've called choosing good
projects and I do this with a lot of the
teams that I work with the problem is
simple there are many uncertainties
there are high risks all over the place
and we're not sure if we're going to
make good choices the solution is to go
and de-risk our uncertainties and two
not de-risk by building models quickly
but the risk by talking to the people in
the organization going and doing the
talking so who's going to use this thing
how would they use it if we could
deliver a solution or maybe the V2 is
the one that integrates in their app and
the V1 is some sort of simple like
delivery but how would they actually
interact with this thing you know can we
ship them a thing that actually will be
valuable at some point in the future or
is for some reason that infeasible
what's valuable to them because probably
they don't care about precision and
recall or r squared or other data
science metrics almost certainly they
care about time saved or money made and
money made the right way not with high
risk potentially high value Solutions
but maybe just really rock solid
reliable Solutions or whatever their
business problem is so we have to go and
figure out what's the right business
metric that we can use to collaborate to
talk about progress on the project from
the business person's point of view we
can ask why should they trust it if they
don't do data science you're ready they
don't collaborate with data science
teams would they trust it what would
help them to trust it what gets them to
believe that we're delivering something
valuable for them and even if I've been
given stakeholders too much stakeholders
actually have time I've had a client
recently where we thought we had
stakeholders but we didn't we kind of
lost three months just waiting for the
stakeholders to give us the feedback
that we need that even on paper we've
said it said that we had these
stakeholders but without them we can't
make the right kind of progress the
anti-pattern here of course is push on
don't worry about those concerns here
we'll figure it all out later none of
those things are actually going to be a
problem you're worrying too much uh
that's the antipant we don't want now
uh one thing that I do when I'm
de-risking as part of this stage is to
use a document to write everything down
write down some kind of de-risk project
specification particularly writing down
watch the value if I don't understand
what the value is what I'm asking all of
these questions I probably don't know
what it is that I need to ship to this
end user and that could be a whole
product in itself just figuring out
where the value is so I recommend you
ask these kind of questions and you
write down the answers
next topic so what does the data mean
I'm not saying what do the ints and the
floats and the strings mean but what
does actual data mean in the real world
um I've been told repeatedly here just
go and do this data science project and
I say great is the data good and they go
yeah of course there's loads of it it's
clean it's wonderful and I say great how
do you consume it how do you report upon
it how do you do machine learning on it
they go oh we've never done that we've
never actually looked at it but I tell
you it's clean and perfect and great and
I know that they're mistaken really I
say look you're lying to me you don't
mean to lie to me but you don't know
your data's any good and there's no
pressure to make it good it's probably
bad and that probably means my life is
going to be very difficult so we need to
go and ask the questions what does the
data mean what does it represent does it
represent a useful version of reality do
we capture enough stuff to answer the
question that we're being set do
outsources fill in the same data
consistently every year or does every
year the outsourcer choose a different
one to three or one to five or one per
10 scale and then never document it I've
come across that it's the kind of thing
that kills projects but the numbers are
all the same there were no missing value
except it looks fine until you ask
questions about what does this mean
so we need to know if the data is sane
and stable
so I'll give you a couple of ways that I
do that when I teach my software
engineering for data scientists class
I'm all over Pandera that's bottom left
so this is a way of making sure my data
is stable so with Pandora I put a schema
around my pandas data frame it's a super
simple idea this column should have
integers they should all be positive
greater than zero they should be unique
and they should be an ascending sequence
this column should have strings that are
at least three characters long and
always uppercase and from this closed
set of strings so you can specify
standard checks or custom checks and
even relationships and statistical
relationships between your columns
inside your uh your pandas data frame so
that's really nice you can tighten down
the specification there and I know that
my spec is great because I've been told
it's going to work and I've got it in
the data that I've been given but then
when I get the next data done from
someone this month's results rather than
last month's I can run it through my
Checker and just confirm that everything
is good and when I say same data Maybe
the top right corner I'm using pandas
profiling to sit with my client and say
look I I've got this distribution of
Ages on this univariate analysis these
are just makes sense do we really have a
few but still some very young and very
old people is that right for this data
set and does this distribution of
categorical items in this columns that
kind of make sense for the kind of
problems that we're looking at here
um and I'm playing with Lux which is
kind of an interesting tool it goes the
next level it it tells you when you're
introspecting your data hey have you
tried this relationship have you looked
at this other column which segments it
in a certain way so it tries to assist
you into looking into your data I bet
you've got a whole bunch of tools that
you use in your kind of data de-risking
and exploratory data analysis we've got
our Discord Channel The Talk discussions
Channel I've already shared a bunch of
links to these in that Discord Channel
if you could go and share some of the
libraries that you like in there that
would help us all learn about new tools
that we could use for these kind of
challenges
so here's our pattern our second pattern
for de-risking data the problem is we've
got gigabytes of data but no business
understanding we don't know what those
bits actually mean the solution of
course is business collaboration
go and ask somebody how does the
business operate why does it make this
kind of data let me draw your diagram
you can tell me if I understand the
process flow of how this stuff works and
what we're going to do with it is it
stable is this year's data the same as
next year's data you can ask a
stakeholder do you trust your own data
and every now and again and get a
stakeholder saying wow you know we're
always kind of suspicious about that
data we were hoping you could tell us
that it's amazing I'm not the right
person to advise if their data is
correct and so that can lead to some
really interesting questions that might
kill or change a project early on before
you're on the hook for delivering
something that makes no sense and took
you three months to develop
the antipant of course is just exploit
the data all the truth is in the data it
represents everything and it's correct
and if you haven't asked the questions
is the data correct did somebody type it
incorrectly do we trust it do you report
upon it a data could just be wrong and
then you'd be wasting your time making
brilliant models that are really
predictive but on something that doesn't
match reality it's just a waste of a lot
of time
researching our third topic so we need
to use our time efficiently to make good
progress and hands up
um I've earned a lot of my time making
poor decisions by getting so excited I
just keep on cracking away on the
keyboard playing with lots of ideas and
it doesn't quite work it doesn't quite
work it doesn't quite we're going to
keep going on the solution of course is
just go for a little walk clear your
head have a little something and you
realize you've made a mistake you've
been asking the wrong question you
should go back and ask a better question
I keep on asking myself and my team now
what are the uh the next what's the next
best decision that we could make that
gets us closer to shipping not closer to
learning a cool thing about some
interesting paper we've read but simply
closer to shipping a thing of value and
that's a nice way to constrain down on
possibilities you might say I've got
loads of ideas and I'm going to try them
all then I'll think about whether
they're working or not but that's a
really poor way to use time it can be
creative but normally it's a poor way to
use time
again if you can go to the talks
discussion channel in Discord and share
any diagnostic libraries like the ones
I'm about to show that'll be super
useful
so part of productive research I think
is being really kind of boring kind of
engineering focused so what is it that
my predictive model or my descriptive
statistic whatever I've got what is it
that it's getting most wrong why is it
getting it that wrong if I can figure
out why it's wrong I can brainstorm
possible solutions with my colleagues
and we could rank them by risk and
difficulty time involved new data that
might be required and then we end up
with a boring predictable process for me
it's a super exciting process because
it's probably going to work I'm probably
going to use my time effectively doing
interesting things that have aligned
with the business that let me discover
interesting things about exploiting this
data and shipping something of value to
do that we need diagnostic tools and
I've got two here on screen uh top right
I've got one of these shap Diagnostics
so shap is a diagnostic machine learning
Tool uh this is taken from the home page
on a text processing problem this is an
example of a kind of thing where I'd sit
down with an internal colleague and say
hey look I've got uh I've got this
example in my text processing sentiment
analysis set and we can see the weights
behind the sentence what a great movie
if you have no taste and then that
colleague might say well look water and
great movie strong positive that makes a
lot of sense and then if you have no
taste that's only got a small negative
but it flips the meaning of the sentence
entirely around and I might go oh crikey
you know I realize now actually that's
incredibly wrong that the model is just
doing the wrong answer here it thinks
it's positive not negative
um so I can think of a research plan so
I go and identify these kind of
sarcastic messages and then do something
about it then the colleague might say
you know but Ian we're hardly going to
have any sarcasm in the Target data set
that we're using so actually this
although it will be embarrassing to find
it we're only going to find like five
cases I don't really care about them
they're a way more important other
problems to go and solve let's go and
solve those so then I learned something
more about the actual end need for my
user and the value to them with these
kind of errors in the system bottom
right we've got the lime diagnostic tool
again for machine learning another
popular Tool uh really interesting for
text analysis
they've got a paper that shows that with
the 20 News Group challenge so use Net
News groups
um you can there are lots of classifiers
that tell you which News Group the test
comes from
um and then they all do really well it
looks brilliant and it's generalized and
it's great for production but it turns
out when you analyze the words that are
important you get words like rice or owl
net you put it in context on an email
and then you find out that actually the
model is picking up on domain names and
college universities rather than the
subject matter of the actual message if
you strip out all of that metadata then
the classifier tends to pick up on
people's names which are also highly
correlated with the classes that you're
disambiguating if you take out the
people's names then it starts to pick up
on the content of the messages and then
you would see all the coloring in the
actual message and that's when you
realize actually this thing's
generalizing now so sitting down with
your colleagues showing how your machine
learning model is working and embedding
it in their real data so they can
understand it incredibly important
so here's our third pattern productive
research here's the problem you've got
lots of data we've got lots of ideas
what should we do first uh the solutions
are repeatable process benchmarking so
coming up with a nice Baseline result I
know what it is that I need to beat uh
coming up with model ideas having some
diagnosis being clear as to why this
thing isn't working and what will
probably make it work better and then
iterate improving and improving my
Benchmark improving my baselines the
anti-pattern and I come across this a
lot when I work with teams let's hack
away I've got loads of ideas uh I'll get
around to using Source control later but
it's just me and my machine and my
colleague right now I don't need to
Source control anything let's keep it
all in the same folder I've only got a
thousand images here to go and click
between I know what they all mean and
I'm going to copy paste between all of
my notebooks and everything's great I'm
sure there's no bugs in here and I I bet
that it's probably going to work at the
end of the day that's just a bad pattern
it's not a reliable saying pattern super
exciting when you're iterating quickly
and maybe you do it for a week or two
but then you've got to come down to a
nice staying stable pattern which means
you can go for the next couple of years
improving things
when do I make a delivery it is our
fourth problem and pattern a demo on
your laptop is not a usefully deployed
system uh with one of my clients I
remember sitting down with the team and
saying great we ship it a few months
time I've been asked to come in and do a
review on your code and see if there's
any pointers I can give you you've got
this uh sequence of machine learning
models feeding into each other
um I can imagine that errors might
propagate through this process so let's
start at the beginning when you put a
document in at one end do you get the
right kind of answer out at the other
end it looked they went oh we haven't
done that test well what do you test I
would put yeah a thing in here and we
get a thing out here and we put a singer
here and we get a thing out here under
the sequence we've never really tried
tying it together I said well great can
we like write a batch file and just tie
it all together well some of the
machines uh are running this as a bunch
of notebooks and mind machine has got
some modules that run some of it and
then our colleagues machine has got some
other bits and we've got all these
different versions of course we haven't
quite brought it all together but we're
shipping three months so that you've got
nothing to actually ship that works how
about we stop and just think about the
end-to-end solution and do that because
otherwise we're never going to get to
make a delivery I've had it teams tell
me the biggest problem in the project is
they need six months to spin up a
machine and I said actually the biggest
problem is I haven't met the client I
haven't seen the data we haven't
actually checked if we've got a problem
to solve yet but you're asking me for a
for a schema for a machine that I have
to create that will take six months to
order and you tell me this is the
biggest problem in the organization I
think actually the fact that I've never
even met the client that's probably a
bigger problem so figuring out how we
make a delivery early on and then
knowing that we've theorist everything
else that we've talked about incredibly
important shipping of E1 which is a
couple of if then else rules the de-risk
the deployment process which is super
cool idea you can take the template
classifier and psychic learn wire it
together with some rules that are easily
explainable to your colleague maybe a
two-layer decision tree so it can make
four decisions perhaps something is
slightly better than just a baseline
random guess but ship that and then keep
on shipping new things showing value
that's a good idea
so here's our pattern delivering value
early the problem is we need to get
results into the hands of our end users
really we want to be talking about
iterative deployment so quickly shipping
something basic and then we keep
shipping something better I'm a huge fan
of taking CSV files giving them to a
user or saying actually we can color it
and we can put some column headings on
it and I'll make an Excel file and then
you can play with that and as long as
you could be some interesting feedback
about this then we can think about
updating and doing the next step because
if I'm the one doing all the work hoping
to convince my end user to spend any
time at all looking at this thing then
you know that's really hard I really
want them to be on this journey with me
in collaborating and giving me useful
results so with one of our clients uh
looking at diagnosing fraud in a big
system we went from uh look how do we
make a model that will predict fraud
through to actually how do the humans do
this what what data do they have what
kind of payments they look for how
common are these patterns how repeatable
are these patterns and if we automate
some of these patterns we can ship a
thing that just makes it more like that
the human can use these tools to to find
their own fraud and then iteratively
over a period of time we've got to the
point where we said actually this thing
in the top like 20 predictions it's
finding a couple of cases of fraud for
you so all of a sudden you know that you
can easily find fraud in there but that
took quite a long time but it meant that
our colleague was on board with us they
enjoyed the journey they weren't getting
increasing value out of the system they
would give us loads of feedback pointing
out all the mistakes that we were making
because we didn't know any better
because we weren't fraud Specialists who
were learning their domain and that
means that we got a good chance to
deliver the thing that was actually
valuable to them over time the
anti-pattern deployment is somebody
else's problem I've written my code it's
in a Jupiter notebook I've got variable
names A B C D E I'm going to Chuck it
over the wall and then it's up to that
Java engineer over there to rewrite the
code and turn it into something valuable
because I don't really care about that
so that's kind of the messy business
problem I don't care about that
you need to care about that your team
needs to care about that because there
will be a V2 and a V3 and if your V1 is
fundamentally wrong you are not going to
look cool so you need your team to think
about that I'm not saying you need to
become also expert data engineers and
expert deployment people you just need
to work in collaboration with the right
team to make sure that the thing that is
coherent and correct is shipped early
and then you keep on shipping better and
better versions of that over time
oh
so build it and they will or won't come
uh we want to impact our user can we get
them to trust us
um we need to use those Diagnostics
building up trust is a really really
difficult thing
um maybe we can take the machine
learning that we've started with and
then rather sitting down with someone
who's a business Expert but they know
nothing about data science rather than
drawing them diagrams I had a colleague
print out big A3 printouts of random
Forest tree sets and then trying to walk
the clients or the individual decisions
it was a beautiful idea but it was it
was Impractical our client didn't care
uh inside this organization they didn't
care about random Forest they cared
about the answer I remember in one of
those meetings just saying hang on a
minute I think we've lost our client how
about we go back to that shap Diagnostic
and we show a couple of cases that the
client can choose they know the data and
in one of those early meetings they just
went you know I kind of get it I kind of
get why the thing is getting more likely
or less likely but also what about these
other factors that are incredibly
important and we've scratched ahead and
said that's not in our data and I said
oh you do know about those other tables
right for these special cases oh we
didn't know about that should we gain
trust by iterating and then after a
couple more meetings we got to the point
where the client went hey you know I
trust it that this makes sense I
understand the explanations I understand
the outputs and the drivers for it I
don't understand the math but I'm cool
with the fact that the numbers make
sense so yeah sure I'd like to use your
system
when you ship a thing and one of your
colleagues diagnoses and goes yeah the
machine's got it wrong it's annotated
that document incorrectly and then you
get the boss to come and look at it
actually I think the machine got it
right and I disagree with my colleagues
reasoning for that particular case when
you've got the humans disagreeing over
which of them is more right and whether
the machine is right with them or right
with the other that's when you're making
human level errors rather than boring
silly errors that's kind of an
interesting point I think at that point
you've kind of made it
so here's our final pattern creating
change and the thing to recognize here
is getting someone to try your solution
is risky for that end user so if you
haven't taken them on that Journey then
you're forcing them to do something and
if they're following the data Science
World they'll keep coming across those
horror stories that just say data
science keeps delivering failed projects
that never go anywhere to cost center
not Value Center and these people will
be scared of getting involved with you
and being forced to do something that's
going to negatively impact their role so
build trust iterates and then learn
those critical lessons about the data
and their processes and what's valuable
to them keep making improvements and
then you'll get to a point where the
client says hey actually you know I want
that next delivery because you're going
to make my life easy but when can I get
that next delivery I really want it uh
and the antipan there is just saying ah
they use it what do they know they don't
care about precision and recall and r
squared that's what I care about I'm
going to keep on improving my numbers
and then they will love it in the end
and of course they won't don't ignore
the client go wherever the client wants
you to go with the quality and the value
behind the system change your metrics as
necessary to align with the value that
the client needs otherwise you're going
to ship something that works hopefully
it works but doesn't offer the value
that the client needs
so here's a summary of our patterns
we'll have a couple of minutes of
questions first of all choose good
projects it's incredibly important to
start well I have a good list of
projects that you can work through
de-risk the meaning of the data not just
what's in the data but actually the
meaning behind it from a business
perspective do your research
productively have a nice repeatable
diagnosable process where you
collaborate in your team deliver value
early and frequently and create positive
change in the organization that's the
way I think this all has to work
otherwise we end up with more failed
projects and it's really demoralizing
there are two more talks uh the
conference steering a data science
project and the Ten Commandments of
reproducible data science so I think you
should attend those uh and uh in a
couple of hours or an hour's time um
I'll be running an Executives at Pi data
session this will be these sixth or
seventh year that I've run one of these
now
um I've got guest Lauren Alger from PI
data NYC and a colleague of mine Douglas
squirrel uh coming in with a CEO CTO
perspective on how to work with data
science teams and we're going to spend
two hours talking through any problems
around data Science Leadership so if
you're a data science leader or you want
to be a data science leader that's a
zoom call uh it's in the calendar with a
link uh have a look on the schedule
you'll find assuming there come and join
us at three o'clock and stick around for
the two hours and please participate
this is all about asking questions and
sharing answers
so uh come to the session at three
o'clock I'd love it if you turn up
please come and join that Zoom call uh
if you want to get some uh some more
ideas from this kind of topic have a
look at my newsletter not a numbered or
email and you'll see all the back
archives are available there for free
um all of my past talks are available on
my blog um and if I've taught you
something interesting I love receiving a
fiscal poster I don't know if on the
camera you can see uh the wall behind me
I've got postcards up I love receiving
postcards I've got them all around my
office they remind me um that I'm
offering uh something useful when I get
these talks right that'll be the end of
my talk thank you very much for having
me there's a couple of minutes of
questions or we can carry on in Discord
afterwards thanks very much
all right thanks Ian glad to have you
here
um
do you want to be taking questions from
the from the comments or you'll be
taking them from the Discord Channel
later on uh we could do them in Disco
but if there's a minute or two to uh ask
any questions now I'm happy to take them
so all right I think we'll be moving to
the Discord and uh the next part is
going to be moving to the keynote given
by Ada okay sure again thank you for
having you thank you for coming to the
presentation thank you very much good to
be here